[Musique]
une commission permanente décentralisée
s'est déroulée ce mercredi 17 mai 2023
braspanon à l'occasion de la foire
agricole
l'agriculture faisait bien entendu
partie des dossiers votés mais également
la modernisation territoriale
l'environnement l'éducation le social
l'insertion la culture et le sport
c'est un signe fort que le département
soit abrapano à l'occasion de la foire
tout simplement parce que c'est un signe
d'abord de respect
envers toutes ces familles ces femmes
ces hommes qui travaillent la paix à
réunionnaise tous les jours
pour nous les meilleurs fruits et
légumes le lait les viandes tout ce que
nous devons consommer et bien la culture
réunionnaise est capable de nous
proposer ces produits là mais il faut
les encourager c'est pour ça que nous
sommes ici à Bravado et je salue ben le
travail qui est réalisé par la
municipalité avec les années 80 mais
aussi le service et tous les partenaires
Chambre d'Agriculture et tous les autres
qui se mobilisent chaque année moi je
crois fortement à la réduction à
réunionnaise et tout le monde le sait
mettre la main dans la terre pour
planter récolter ça il fait pas peur à
moi et c'est notre histoire c'est notre
tradition c'est notre économie c'est
notre patrimoine
de rayonner
que de soutenir l'agriculture
après avoir visité quelques stands le
président a tenu à saluer les seniors
lors du traditionnel balle la poussière
une conférence de presse est ensuite
tenue pour accueillir les nouveaux
adhérents à la marque 100% la Réunion
mise en place par le Département
ce label nous l'avons mis en place
depuis la fin de l'année 2022 et la
volonté pardon du conseil départemental
c'est de pouvoir mettre en avant la
production locale la production pays et
nous avons donc décliné ce label 100% la
Réunion en trois en trois marques le
100% Réunion c'est la production de ce
qui nous arrive de la terre la récolte
tout simplement des produits et des
fruits légumes de la réunion nous avons
mis également le 100% bio-réunion pour
reconnaître des exploitations qui se
sont engagées dans l'agriculture
biologique et enfin le 100% excellence
qui concerne les produits qui ont été
primés sur le plan national ou
international ça peut être des produits
je dirais
issus de l'agro transformation
issus également de nos exploitations
agricoles la grosse tourisme fait partie
aussi de notre volonté de mettre en les
acteurs du monde agricole local cette
nouvelle sélection compte 25 nouveaux
agriculteurs pour environ 200 produits
pour moi c'est un gage de qualité déjà
en plus de notre certification bio nous
on est déjà dans la démarche où on veut
être quand même dans un dans une
démarche de qualité donc le 100% pays ou
100% réunion pour nous c'est une marque
de c'est une gage de qualité et c'était
pour surtout aussi pour la traçabilité
des produits nous on sait que nos
produits sort de chez nous produits là à
la Réunion et transformer à la Réunion
donc pour les pour nos consommateurs
c'est important de d'avoir la
traçabilité de des produits qui
consomment
une commission permanente qui a été
aussi l'occasion pour le département de
renforcer son soutien au monde agricole
avec une dotation de 730 000 euros
[Musique]